wow hey guys just wanna let you know
that i was assigned earlier today to the
g2e conference okay so i had to
interview
vanna white guys
so i asked her two things all right one
what makes you and your family come to
las vegas all the time and two give me a
nugget a secret that nobody knows about
you
on the set here's what she had to say
i love vegas i love
the gambling part i love the incredible
restaurants
the the shows
you know when you come here you just
have a good time it's like being in
adult disneyland it really is and every
time i come here
when i leave i feel fulfilled i feel
happy it's like a great escape
i have snacks behind the puzzle board
nobody knows that right yeah they always
put like nice little things back there
like cookies and donuts and peanuts and
so that's something that nobody really
that's behind the actual screens that
you touch yeah it is what is there is
there a favorite of yours like chips
ahoy or something
no it's always different i never know i
have to say it must be the donuts though
i think it's the donuts that i like
because i don't get donuts at home
guys look at that
she has snacks behind her touch board
which is crazy because i do too
there you go
i'm just like vanna
not crazy though something that we did
not know about wheel of fortune which
airs tonight